[Musique]
mon soir bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 débat il ya cinq mois le
gouvernement lancé le grand débat
national
objectif redonner la parole aux français
améliorer la démocratie participative et
l'engagement citoyen à l'échelle locale
justement il existe différentes manières
de s'engager avec notamment les conseils
de quartier ou encore les associations
alors ces outils sont ils suffisants que
faudrait-il faire en plus pour renforcer
justement cet engagement citoyen c'est
le thème du débat du jour et pour en
parler sans qu invité autour de cette
table et violon de change bonjour
bonjour vous êtes vice président du coc
des skis locaux d'esquisser le conseil
de développement de saint quentin en
yvelines rapidement quelles sont vos
missions
alors dans la composition peut être
rapidement dans ces 96 membres qui sont
désignés par le président de
l'agglomération et les mers va
principalement par les maires et par le
président de l'agglomération issus de
différents milieux de la caractéristique
c'est d'avoir effectivement une
diversité de points de vue autour de la
table donc les milieux économiques les
milieux associatifs des citoyens et puis
des personnes dites qualifiées donc la
commission va c'est de réfléchir et de
donner un avis sur les politiques
communautaires un fait politique de
l'agglomération donc pratiquement nous
avons toutes les politiques tous les
programmes ou les plans comme le plan de
l'habitat le plan d'urbanisme
le projet de territoire sur des sujets
de société par exemple actuellement nous
avons un groupe de fonds que de deux
projets qui travaillent sur la question
de la jeunesse parce qu'on s'est
interrogé notamment dans le cadre du
plan local de l'habitat
/
enfin on a constaté que les jeunes
quittent est majoritairement le
territoire et voudrait savoir pourquoi
donc on a on a lancé une enquête que
nous sommes en train de dépouiller sur
essentiellement le logement les
déplacements et la qualité de vie à
saint quentin en yvelines pour un jeune
voilà et puis tout autre sujet soit sur
saisine de du président de
l'agglomération soit de notre propre
initiative et notamment la l'étude sur
les jeunes
c'est dans le cadre d'une auto saisie
alors vos costea d'un caf un bon soir il
était vice président du conseil de
quartier centre village pour la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux là aussi rapide
présentation de ce conseil de quartier
combien de membres depuis quand existe
t-il c'est quelque chose qui dure depuis
au moins une dizaine d'années on est
chargé pour compte de la mairie d'avoir
des relations avec les habitants et de
recueillir les difficultés qui peuvent
avoir et de les retransmettre à la
mairie où là aussi de s'autosaisir dans
ce nombre de sujets donc évidemment
globalement c'est comme des sujets assez
proche des terrains dont ces sujets sur
souvent la voirie la sécurité pour les
piétons l'entretien des choses de gens
mais parfois des sujets plus plus plus
large et plus grande intensité
ce sont des personnes qui sont
uniquement à voisins sur la base du
volontariat on est il ya trois conseils
de quartier voisin on est entre 15 et 35
personnes à peu près donc on a deux
trois ans et on travaille comme ça
avec la mairie évidemment donc ca
politique on ne défend pas nos intérêts
personnels en défend on travaille pour
la collectivité et on ne défend pas non
plus l'intérêt père celle d'autres
personnes ou de deux personnes morales
comme des salles ou des copropriétés on
travaille pour compte comme un collectif
voilà à vos côtés mamadou soumaré
bonsoir du mans sont à vous êtes
président du conseil de quartier du val
hibou à plaisir là aussi rapide
présentation qui était mon petit peu
comment comment ça fonctionne bonsoir
conseiller quartier de value du plaisir
a été créé en 1970 à 177 95 597 dans les
conseils de quartier il a c'est une
association fédératrice parce qu'il ya
d'autres associations qui sont en avoir
mais un petit con ces quartiers qui se
sont fédératrices
du coup on est là c'est fait la
médiation entre la population et des
institutions dont le but du conseil de
quartier
on attaque on la démission l'émission
c'est une des terreurs lui c'est d'être
là pour s'éclater s'est ralliée
décalogue de concertation et de réponses
se trouver réponse aux problèmes des
quartiers d'assurer le rôle
d'interlocuteur et le médiateur entre la
population et les institutions
construit à la réalisation du projet
collant concernant ma jeunesse à la
famille et la vie associative du
quartier à s'inquiéter au fait des
événements des sorties vient de demander
dans votre concert de cartes conseil de
quartier les adhérents du bruit voilà à
verser 105 personnes
même sans son personnel à prendre le
moindre but on s'est tous un outil zut
alors on parlera évidemment plus
longuement au cours de cette émission
stafa larbaoui bonsoir bonjour vous êtes
président de l'association format
citoyens attrape une association créée
en 2007 ils se ressemblent alors
justement ce qu'on veut nous présenter
cette association quelles sont vos
actions
alors fermez citoyens donc une
association loi 1901 elle a pour objet
finalement c'est de valoriser des
actions on va dire les actions d'oncle
associative à but
encore une fois culturel et en même
temps basé sur le loisir éducatif
voilà l'idée c'est que on fait beaucoup
de choses dans les communes ont fait
beaucoup de choses dans les quartiers
souvent c'est souvent orientés sur le le
loisir pur ou le loisir consomme hâtif
comme je l'appelle c'est pas du tout
l'orientation que nous souhaitons
apporter avec avec toute mon équipe
mais ces deux d'apporter par le biais du
loisir qui est inquiète un bon prétexte
un bon billet toujours ces notions
éducative et qui tourne autour de la
citoyenneté principe de cette adresse
avec les prix jeunes enfants alors on a
un axe fort sur les cm2 donc dix ans on
travaille avec les associations
sportives le club de foot en particulier
mais c'est en train de s'élargir au delà
des du club de foot à d'autres clubs
sportifs et en même temps donc sur
trappe
et c'est en train de s'agrandir
aujourd'hui sur la verrière et les
environs mais c'est vraiment l'idée
c'est vraiment de d'aller sur des
notions de
deux sorties mémorielle il ya des axes
quand même le prioritaire sur des
programmes de cm2 autour de la première
guerre mondial seconde guerre mondial
et puis tout ce qui touche tout ce qui a
trait à ce que l'humanité a pu produire
de meilleur et de pire et de pire on a
vu la traite négrière donc on traite ces
sujets la shoah et puis par exemple le
débarquement qui a eu quand même des
conséquences extrêmement importante pour
l'europe et donc ce sont sur ces thèmes
comme celui ci que l'on travaille
et puis j'ai je préside également une
association que j'ai créé très récemment
qui s'appelle engagement trappe
et là pour le coup c'est un engagement
plus de citoyens mais c'est un citoyen
qui bascule dans la vie politique le
calmer et communales alors à vos côtés
caroline le jargon soir vous êtes
coordinatrice animations au sein du
secours catholique des yvelines aussi
rappelé un petit peu les missions du
secours catholique le secours catholique
est une association généraliste
on peut donner deux grands axes sur sa
mission la première c'est l'éveil à la
solidarité changer le regard que porte
la société sur la pauvreté sur les
personnes qui vivent la pauvreté est la
seconde grande mission c'est la lutte
contre les causes de pauvreté avec les
personnes concernées
donc nos missions et traduit
essentiellement par des actions
mobilisation des personnels même pour
accéder à leurs droits mais aussi de
de médiation auprès des pouvoirs publics
et voilà il vous est implanté un peu
partout dans les îles oui voilà on a
cinquante lieux d'accueil de permanences
d'accueil ouvert à tous on a trois
boutiques
vingt trois épiceries sociales de
boutique solidaire et puis ensuite 20-20
lieu d'accueil où sont développés des
actions collectives
voilà un merci en tout cas tous les cinq
d'avoir accepté l'invitation va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet on va justement
pour commencer à regarder un
micro-trottoir jusqu'au cm bazire et
audrey chaillou sont allés et bien
demandé aux saint quentinois s'il était
engagé dans la vie démocratique ou bien
dans la vie associative on regarde avec
les enfants n'est plus impliqué au
niveau de l'école
ce serait avant tout avant tout à ce
niveau là que
on serait qu'on serait amené à
s'impliquer davantage pour le moment non
mais pas content je donne j'ai fait
beaucoup pour des dons quand je le
téléthon donc tout ça je participe et
voilà je fais des dons beaucoup le
cancer tout ça pour moi ç'a toujours été
important et toujours été de voir je me
dis quand on voit ça je dis moi demain
ça peut m'arriver et chalets content
qu'on m'aide avec la crise que tout ce
qui se passe actuellement donc c'est la
possibilité de d'être dans une
association caritative
pourquoi pas on n'encourage pas assez
les gens à le faire même si c'est sûr il
ya des volontés je trouve que tu
encourages pas assez on ne dit pas assez
dans le truc tu es un peu lâché trouve
tout seul trouve comment faire et c'est
que je trouve ça dommage et ses
associations pas du tout moyen et c'est
encore plus dommage une réaction on a vu
en fait que les gens étaient plus
globalement on va dire engagés dans des
associations plutôt peut-être que dans
la vie démocratique qu'est ce que ça
vous surprend ou pas je prends pas parce
qu'en général les associations sont les
seuls qui sont les plus visibles au
niveau national peut-être est par contre
une démission des associations
pourraient être celles de d'orienter
ensuite les personnes pour qu'elles
contribuent davantage dans leurs
quartiers dans leurs lieux de vie comme
vous le faite vous parlez de visibilité
justement est-ce que les conseils de
quartier c'est assez connus finalement
c'est pas certain je pense que c'est il
ya des choses qu'il faut faire encore
pour aller plus loin là dessus en terme
de communication n'utilise pas encore
assez les outils des réseaux sociaux des
choses comme ça et je pense
qu'effectivement il faut l'améliorer
probablement pareil pour des choses que
le coc des skis et il faut effectivement
qu'on communique davantage qu'on pousse
un petit peu les gens là dessus et sur
un deuxième aspect la luz et enfin la
participation citoyenne et sans doute
pas assez éduqués et rien d'autres
enseignés à l'école et on devrait
pouvoir utiliser aussi ce moyen la peau
progressivement emmener les gens vers ce
type d'activité des des actions au sein
de la ville pour que peu à peu ça
fonctionne toujours parler d'école
justement stafa larbaoui qu'est ce que
vous en pensez que c'est finalement le
éducation civique n'est par exemple
n'est pas assez enseigné à l'école pour
le coup moi je pense plutôt le contraire
sert qu'à chaque fois qu'ils apprennent
dans la société
on se tourne vers les cols blancs là
l'école devrait devrait devrait donc un
problème de citoyenneté
l'école devrait y imprime de civils
l'école devrait devrait il ya un
problème de d'incivilité il ya des
problèmes on va dire récurrent à bien
des égards et souvent se tourner vers
l'école l'école a quand même des
missions bien précises sur probablement
pas forcément l'éducation mais sur la
transmission du savoir et il ya
tellement à faire il ya tellement de
lacunes à mon avis à à combler qu'il
faudrait qu'il reste bien sûr leur
mission et sur leurs objets ce qui me
permet de dire que pour moi la loi 1901
le monde associatif est un merveilleux
outil pour pouvoir promouvoir toutes ces
actions étaient toutes ces façons de
transmettre des valeurs finalement parle
de citoyenneté ce sont des valeurs
occidentales et des valeurs très
française je n'arrive pas à dissocier la
citoyenneté de la révolution française
j'arrive pas à dissocier le citoyen de
ce qu'il est devenu après des luttes
improbable qu'on a pu avoir à l'époque
d'une monarchie où on était tous que des
sujets et on est arrivé jusqu'à une
émancipation où le citoyen devient un
acteur où il a le droit de parole ou la
droite cité il n'est pas sous le joug tu
d'un roi d'un monarque qui a droit de
vie et de man est donc ce citoyen doit
s'emparer de la vie de la cité par
définition et je trouve que le monde
associatif permet cet engagement il
existe par le biais politique le biais
politique il existe mais c'est souvent
les parties qu'il a acquis qu'ils se
l'approprient donc c
le partisan souvent et c'est souvent
très clanique très clivant par contre le
monde associatif c'est justement il ya
un mode démocratique est beaucoup plus
intéressant et qui permet d'aller
beaucoup plus au fond des sujets traités
et de l'objet pour lequel l'association
doit se réaliser
donc je trouve que le monde associatif
devrait être être beaucoup plus encadré
beaucoup plus encadré j'entends ce qu'il
disait d'ailleurs dans le micro je crois
que le rôle d'un maire dans une commune
a donc là on est 36000 communes de
france heureux que le maire devrait
s'impliquer beaucoup plus à fédérer les
associations entraîne d'une part et
avoir une espèce de politique de la
ville autour des associations sur ces
thématiques de la citoyenneté et de
l'engagement je finirai pour pas être
trop long par dire que il ya de moins en
moins quand même de bénévoles j'en
profite pour saluer les miens dans le
club de foot dans pharma citoyens dans
engagement trappe et dans d'autres
associations que j'ai pu présider
ça fait plus de 40 ans que je suis dans
le monde associatif j'ai vraiment le
sentiment qu'il y en a de moins en moins
il ya de moins en moins de bénévoles et
que c'est de plus en plus difficile mais
non pas parce que les gens les familles
les gens auront envie c'est juste qu'il
n'y a pas suffisamment de visibilité sur
les associations pas suffisamment de
reconnaissance non plus de ce monde là
est donc j'évite mois le monde politique
à s'intéresser aux associations et à
donner plus de visibilité plus de
reconnaissance et aux présidents
d'associations à être un peu plus
vertueux quant à l'objet qu'ils
défendent pardon oui non pour revenir à
votre question et cela paraisse par
rapport au micro trottoir quand on
regarde les forums des associations dans
les communes qui sont organisées
annuellement donc à la rentrée de
septembre
et quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'associations et il ya très peu de deux
conseillers de quartier a pas
d'organisme de de démocratie
participative
donc il il est non il est normal que il
ya tellement d'associations qu'il est
normal que les citoyens les connaissent
beaucoup beaucoup plus
d'autre part les associations très tous
les sujets de la vie quotidienne a fallu
aussi le sport la culture et c'est donc
c'est assez c'est assez compréhensible
ce que vous avez recueillis dans le
dans le micro trottoir est d'ailleurs
alors je mettrais un petit peu une
petite réserve est ce que vous avez dit
sur le thème les c'est sûr qu'on peut
demander aux politiques de faire
toujours plus ça c'est mais justement
mon impression c'est que avec tous les
là l'engagement associatif des mers
l'organisation de forums des
associations etc
il ya quand même venu d'abord il ya une
vie associative qui est très riche à
saint quentin en yvelines et d'autre
part et pas mal accompagné me
semble-t-il alors c'est intéressant
d'avoir votre point de vue association
quoi c'est vous êtes pratiquement dans
des organes puisque vous vous croyez
driver de la l'agglomération c'est cela
je pars à du ressenti des gens qui
travaillent dans les associations et
c'est le ressenti que j'ai moi même
c'est même pour ça que l'effet levier je
le trouve maintenant justement dans
l'engagement politique parce que l'effet
levier on pourrait la voir en vo des
associations si les associations étaient
bien perçus comme des gens engagés dans
la vie citoyenne et non pas dans la vie
politique et donc l'effet levier moi je
me trouve maintenant plus facilement
dans l'engagement politique c'est pour
ça que je franchis le pas donc ce que je
vais plus loin dans mon engagement
mais je trouve qu'on ne met pas
suffisamment d'attention sur les
associations c'est mon prono c'est
complètement des jeux son avis à
caroline lejard puisque par rapport à
votre association est ce que votre avis
est ce que vous êtes assez encadré
justement une personne dénoncé un petit
peu un petit peu ça le sentiment cadres
et oui enfin on est une association
assez grosse association donc on
bénéficie d'une grosse visibilité en
tout cas ce que je peux dire c'est qu'en
termes de relations avec les pouvoirs
publics pour les loteries sont plutôt
bons
notre objectif étant de l'elysée lava de
permettre aux personnes les plus
précaires de contribuer à la société et
notamment avec toute l'expérience du
grand débat national
on a une expérience positive de la part
des femmes une réponse positive de la
part des députés qui sont venus à la
rencontre de personnes voilà on a permis
aux personnes de contribuer au grand
débat national grâce à ça j'ai des
jeunes tout à l'heure au niveau des
conseils de quartier on va pas se le
cacher les conseils de quartier sont un
petit peu boudé par les jeunes et est ce
que vous vous avez ce ressenti aussi et
pourquoi finalement les conseils de
quartier sont boudés par les jeunes oui
la grs je comprends les conseils de
quartier pour sont boudés par les jeunes
ont apprécié par les autonomes est la
nôtre est boudé par des jeunes parce que
les jeunes du quartier
by jo lui l'air association à part en
nous aux neuf vous lis quand on a voulu
fusionner avec et la parlant il ne pas
voler pour huer quand ces quartiers et
là c'est les choix de travail pour la
mairie ou travers avec la mairie mais
sauf qu'il n'est pas contre qui on est
tous là pour le même objectif on est
tous là pour le bien-être des quartiers
et pour le mossad pour les voleurs à le
bien-être du peuple de ceux du quartier
dur du peu des habitants de ces
quartiers en particulier
d'une façon générale du tout la ville
des plaisirs comme les êtres quartier et
ils peuvent en profiter de tout ce qu'on
fait pour lui et pour la population et
le cadre est là pour tout le monde
j y viennent s'informer il versait des
informations il va leur proposer
c'est à dire de demander des
informations pour avoir des solutions à
leurs problèmes monsieur gaffe à vos
sentiments aussi par rapport aux jeunes
voilà les conseils de quartiers là par
exemple dans votre conseil de quartier
vous combien de l'heure quand je dis
jeunes on va dire rien de moins non
j'aime
- points 30 ans quitte quasiment aucun
il faut être très clair pour tout ce
genre de choses et là je diverge aura un
petit peu aussi du sud et associations
la station souvent sont des choses abu
actif pour son propre compte
donc on a des choses pour le sport jeux
comme ça donc c'est votre donation pour
finalement consommée ce qu'offre
l'association un conseil de quartier
c'est aussi le cas des codie ce qui
s'est exactement le contraire n'en
tireront aucun bénéfice personnel
on a un engagement au sens littéral
citoyen et civique
ça ne nous apporte rien on y consomme
quand même beaucoup de temps et beaucoup
d'énergie et c'est pas forcément quelque
chose peut-être une question de maturité
au sens de l'âge venant qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup chez des jeunes aujourd'hui et
qui fait que c'est sans doute un
obstacle ce qui rend dans ce genre de
choses ils ont sans doute si la culture
d'un peu l'immédiateté de la
consommation rapide d'un slot de choses
on l'a vu aussi au niveau du grand débat
national
il n'y avait quasiment aucun jeune et
pourtant ce sont des gens qui sont
porteurs dans vie de deux demandes et
d'action et de solutions effectivement
c'était c'est qu'on les a pas vus
puisqu'on parle d'engagement citoyen je
voudrais rapidement parler du service
national universel puisqu'il a été lancé
il ya à peu près dix jours alors le
département d ib n'en est pas un pour le
moment en tout cas concerné que qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que l'uniforme les règles de vie
militaire est ce que là aussi ça
pourrait justement pousser à plus
d'engagement citoyen notamment à chez
ces jeunes qu'est ce qu'est ce que vous
pensez du service national universel
c'est sauf facile d'en parler quand on a
passé l'âge ne pas avoir à le faire
je me souviens du service militaire où
tout le monde essaie de l'éviter à
l'époque donc là aujourd'hui je pourrais
vous dire que très sincèrement ça me
paraît très bonne chose
alors c'est à l'expérimentation donc on
verra ce que l'expérience portera mais
bien sûr que c'est une bonne chose à
partir du moment où on a cette vocation
est ce cet objectif de faire en sorte
que l'on puisse faire passer certains
messages très tôt et très jeune
voilà donc je suis un peu gêné parce que
je sais que je vais pas avoir à le faire
mais j'aurais quand même dire un mot
concernant les associations les
associations pour le coude porté sur la
notion de citoyenneté
ce qui me gêne justement c'est que on va
trop vers le consommateur pas
suffisamment vers l'éducatif et dans la
notion de citoyenneté
je crois qu'il faut pas oublier de le
rappeler c'est qui à la fois les droits
j'ai parlé de révolution est allé
jusqu'à chercher des actes des choses
qui sont des actifs de nos jours mais je
crois qu'il faut vraiment porter une
attention particulière également sur les
devoirs et donc un citoyen se doit de
marcher sur deux jambes mais ses deux
jambes c'est celle là c'est vraiment le
droit à beaucoup de choses et les
devoirs à autant de choses parce que
l'idée c'est quand même que chacun se
devienne celui qui doit devenir en
termes de personnalité et mais qu'ils
puissent respecter surtout l'autre qui
le deviennent aussi à sa place dans ces
notions de droits et de devoirs sont des
notions important je parle bien
d'engagements à la fois de devenir
citoyen et pour ceux qui s'engagent des
cas les bénévoles que je représente
aujourd'hui on vraiment cette vocation à
vouloir aider à devenir le citoyen qui
est celui qui et qui a des droits qui
doit respecter les autres danses et par
ses devoirs oui très bonne initiative
on va en tirer l'expérience voulait
réagir sur ce registre la citoyenneté
dans la prof sous l'angle
de l'éthique du débat à la fois
personnelles dans le respect des autres
on observe dans les revendications
sociales
les gens quelquefois il affirme alors
qu'il affirme effectivement quelles sont
leurs revendications leur mal-être leurs
difficultés ça c'est absolument légitime
et c'est le point de départ de tout
c'est la base de tout mais à partir de
là il ya besoin d'entrer dans un débat
d'abord pour comprendre aussi pour les
problèmes des autres ensuite
de savoir si la perception qu'on a de la
réalité globale elle correspond à la
réalité ou pas quand même beaucoup de
plus de désinformation de fake news
comme on dit donc un vrai débat se doit
de commencer à faire un petit peu le
trident du vrai du faux
et puis ensuite rechercher des solutions
fortes rechercher des solutions en
écoutant un petit peu les propositions
des autres
en recherchant quand même un certain
réalisme ne peut pas avoir tout tout de
suite
donc le fait éventuellement du rachis et
dans le temps ou ne pas aviser la
solution qui va apporter la réponse à
tout mais savoir transiger tout ceci
c'est sur des attitudes de respect de
l'autre des cultes de de louis de
respect de l'opinion face de tolérance
aussi et en même temps de discipline de
soi aussi de voilà donc tout ça
s'apprend et le débat est une occasion
de l'apprendre s'il est bien conduit
dans cet esprit là et donc je vous
rejoins tout à fait sur le fait qu'il ya
des devoirs la citoyenneté c'est c'est
une responsabilité d'abord une
responsabilité personnelle de conduire
sa vie et d'écouter les autres avec
respect et avec en en n'étant pas trop
centré alors on est bien on arrive
bientôt en fait à la fin de l'émission
je voulais vous poser à chacun une
question je vais commencer par vous
caroline de jaar pourquoi vous avez
décidé de vous engager au sein du
secours catholique catholique ou
peut-être même sur d'autres associations
oui et c'est peut-être étudiante je ne
sais pas mais pourquoi finalement cette
envie de s'engager
déjà par culture familiale je pense que
très vite un clic et beaucoup de valeur
et de sensibiliser en tout cas tout
voilà l'engagement citoyen et la
pauvreté et que j'ai commencé par
m'engager dans une association quartier
ou valdocco argenteuil et voilà ça m'a
donné envie de poursuivre et de même de
me professionnaliser et maintenant je
suis à l'arrêt dans une association mais
de son art et pourquoi vous avez décidez
vous de vous engager dans ce conseil de
quartier du vélib ou un plaisir conseil
quartier devenu un plaisir parce que
déjà j'habite à plaisir et quand
j'habitais là bas j'étais pas en marge
est parti faire du parti passer mon
temps la loi donc j'ai vécu je suis là
tout le temps donc il est grand temps
qu'ils se divisent utile pour les autres
en se disant à rien qu'ils viennent ici
pour parler avec les gens s'en fait une
ouverture de connaître des personnes des
mêmes par exemple d'avoir des
informations
donc je me suis dit que pourquoi pas
être là et d'être utile pour les autres
donc plus grand plaisir pour moi c'est
de faire plaisir aux autres
alain caffort même question pourquoi cet
engagement
peut-être vous étiez aussi engagée avant
que plus jeune peut-être dans deux
associations en fait j'ai tellement
c'était le cas quand mais avant que ma
vie professionnelle ne me prennent
quasiment 100 150 3 % de mon temps
donc là ayant cessé mes activités
professionnelles j'ai à nouveau du temps
disponible comme j'ai quand même encore
beaucoup d'énergie d'idées de choses
comme ça si bas autant de données à
disposition de la collectivité et
participer aux actions des genres est
d'aider à faire aventis et des sujets
sur voisins dans par exemple un gros
problème de circulation étaient au delà
de la commune qui on travaille largement
au delà du quartier du centre ville en
collaboration avec la mairie qui nous
soutient pour les compositions de
avoir des avancées on a des contacts
avec l'équipe mobilité de l'ass qui on
travaille beaucoup de gens et on espère
bien victime en contribuant à un bleu
mans à faire avancer les choses pour
notre commune
il entre les communes autour 30 secondes
s'était engagé dans une association et
le président de l'apn est ce qu on ne
veut pas pour ne pas la citer le
président de cette association qui était
membre du codis qui m'a invité à venir
participer aux réunions du groupe
culture de ce kit qu'il présidait et je
me suis pris au jeu
ce que je trouve que c'était passionnant
effectivement de s'intéresser à la chose
publique à regarde exactement comment ça
se sait comment dire s'établissait se
préparait les décisions ce instruisent
les dossiers et et comment les gt1
fortement intéressés à faire en sorte
que les citoyens puissent effectivement
être partie prenante dans ce processus
de préparation de la décision et ensuite
de suivi de sa mise en oeuvre
safa larbaoui 35 tordu la main par le
monde associatif
j'essaye de tendre la mienne au plus
possible voilà je me sens responsable de
beaucoup de choses et donc pour le coup
j'ai envie de vrais et partager comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure
merci quand vous voulez qu à tous les
cinq d'avoir accepté cette invitation
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 débat
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
à très bientôt
[Musique]